you say that you need something to help
you bring you to the edge is this part
of the human experience to
um
or the human burden is this a burden in
our life that helps us learn lessons to
have that sort of
breaking the lines aspect to us so you
can call it breaking the line
essentially
it is a freedom offered only to the
human being in this
massive life that exists on this planet
for all of them clearly drawn out lines
by nature you can do this you cannot do
this you're a tiger you're a lion you're
a grasshopper you're an earthworm
whatever the hell you are including the
virus okay right lines are fixed by
nature
for you lines are not fixed so human
beings are not suffering their bondages
they're suffering their freedom because
they don't know how to deal with it
let's unpack that
it's the freedom that there's the
freedom that they're suffering why do
you think everybody is trying to bind
themselves to somebody
because they cannot be free if they are
free they feel terrified
somebody has to hold their hand all the
time
see i cannot live without you
or i can
you taking
whether i say i cannot live without you
or i cannot walk without a crotch what
is the difference i'm asking
see right now we made it very romantic
yes if i say i cannot live without you
that's supposed to be the best thing no
i can live perfectly without you right
but by choice i'm having you here right
isn't this a great thing right
absolutely i cannot live without you you
you're my crutch why do we use those
words then those are the romantic words
because i can't live without you why do
we use those words that is because your
life is being shaped by sappy novels and
hollywood
last seen
to have lived happily ever after kind of
scenes i think those scenes are
generally gone these days they're from
scenes from 60s 70s
80s also maybe to some extent
um it's so true it is true you there
there is a programming that comes from
television from books uh and and do you
think this is commercial commercial
forces are determining your
consciousness that's the sickest way to
develop a human society but it's
happening right of course
big time do you watch tv
news channels
not every day i would like to but
in united states i don't even get to
read a newspaper there isn't any
newspaper anywhere in any home
in india in every home there will be a
newspaper in our homes there will be
five
news five editions of different brands
of newspaper because we have to look at
a newspaper online in news is there but
it's not the same thing
television
indian television has become full of
debates not much news you have to search
for news
and every two minutes somebody will come
and send a
sell a hammer an underwear anything
yeah in the in your face
to get 10 minutes of news you'll have to
buy a hammer a screwdriver an underwear
a car and whatever
very expensive to watch the news so you
have to keep shifting to five different
channels to get little bit of news here
there there
programming and purchasing
so what is the right programming then
freedom means no programming program
means you're set
no freedom freedom means to be able to
live here without a program
what's the definition of
nirvana
nirvana before i know it's a popular
word in california nirvana means
non-existence are you ready for that
right
you want nirvana you can hat you have no
programming essentially then no
non-existence that you don't exist are
you ready for non-existence people are
just using these words picked up from
books and scriptures i've been thinking
a lot about abracadabra and how
words
are
spells
and so that feels like
of course programming that you get from
your television or your newspaper and
the words that you say to each other
like
i can't live without you
it's powerful in a good and bad way when
i say i cannot live without you
what is being satisfied within you is
your insecurity right
that you have hold over me
if i say
i can live absolutely joyfully without
with without you
but
i'm choosing to have you here
this is valuable
this is the best acknowledgement for who
you are exactly i cannot live without
you you could as well be a stick that i
hold and walk
so that should be
how you address the person that you love
then right that should be the new the
new words are
i don't need you but i'm glad you're
here this is a joyful experience but i
don't need you
that's the most loving thing you could i
understand that i agree
i i agree i i i think that uh of course
needing anything is see we have raised
need about joy need about love need
about freedom needs are everything
because it's a market economy if you
don't have needs what will the economy
do are they going to sell you don't need
anything what do they sell
i'm not good for the economy they're
telling me
they tell me sadhguru you don't have
credit history
i say isn't it good i've never taken a
loan isn't it great
they said no you have no credit history
you have no value in united states you
must buy something
i think i don't need anything why should
i buy something
we play into that system your book
karma and i have been reading a lot
about karma and i've always read a lot
about karma and i'm sure i use it in the
wrong context but in all of the things
that i've watched and read and and
understood within me feels like
karma is some is is could be also
another word that could be used as
perception
is that accurate um
karma is post perception perception has
happened
the residual impact of perception is
karma the residual impact
see right now whatever you perceive
right
all of it may not remain in the
conscious plane of who you are right now
you look like this there are
a hundred different shades of green out
there right
you may not be conscious about it
but all of it has been captured by your
eye and registered somewhere within you
so next time you see that
it will naturally make its own judgments
the dark green may create fear in you
light green may create joy in you i'm
saying
just ad hoc i'm just saying but i'm
saying different colors different tastes
different smells different sounds create
either fear or joy in you your race car
if my
father heard that race car engine he
would have a nervous breakdown really
yeah yeah he hated my motorcycle when i
revved up because i'm just tuning it and
ma'am if i do that shut up
so he hates your race car but for you
it's like music
the smell of oil and gas
that's all pollution that's called
pollution in california but it smells
good to me that's my perception
it's perfume that is your karma
because
what everybody pursues gasoline smell as
gasoline smell
they may not call that call it by that
name but it's the same smell
but one person
registers it as a wonderful thing
another person says this is pollution
it's not perfume
so
how you register it and how it remains
within you that's your karma that will
determine the next moment's experience
for you right not allowing that to
determine your next moment's hex
experience is freedom what is it that we
get wrong about karma and understanding
it who is that we
most people
everything wrong
[Laughter]
i know
i know that's why i'm coming to you um
but i feel like you know
karma there's a there's a there's a
perception that karma perception of the
perception uh that you know you do
something bad and then something
you know you get away with it and
something but i feel like that's not an
accurate or or deep enough understanding
of cars first of all how do you decide
something is bad racing is bad okay
racing is bad a whole lot of people
now because uh you know my truck has
gone on the instagram or something a
whole lot of people are saying this is a
crime when india is suffering from
pandemic he is driving a truck
what would you want me to drive a
helicopter i can do that a plane i can
do that a boat i can do that what would
you what would you want me to drive no
i'll tell you this one day i'm driving
you know like i'm going to a conference
in chennai in southern india
somebody else is driving now it's very
rare that somebody else drives it's
somebody else's car they're driving i'm
staying in someone's home
and they're driving in a very civilized
way and we're not going anywhere
chennai needs a little forceful driving
otherwise you won't get anywhere
it's getting late for me and
i've maintained this in the last 39
years i have not been late to a single
event in my life
so
speed is a part of that that i get there
and i hear you
so i i so in a traffic lamp i told the
driver you just get off
i made him get off i got in and started
driving
so i got to the hotel where the
conference was
you know these days after that mumbai
terrorist attack in every star hotel
good hotel that you go to there is a
security gate
there's two security guys who definitely
do not know what they're looking for
okay
they will just look at you like this
like this they don't see a damn thing
you can see that
and he just opens the boot and closes it
he doesn't see anything and he puts a
mirror under the car
that you're carrying a bomb like that
i'm carrying a bomb under my seat how
will you see it
only thing is he's thinking he will
scare the terrorists he'll make him
nervous and catch him
but anyway that little barrier which is
there a terrorist will crash through
that and go
it is not a barrier that can stop a car
i'm saying right
so anyway one car went and this thing
went up and i squeezed myself through
that and when then everybody started
blowing their whistles
i just went parked in the portion of the
thing i just left the car there and ran
into the conference hall straight on the
stage
spoke for an hour
hour and then i came when i ran in i saw
some journalists standing there they saw
me they thought this is it we caught him
you know
i didn't break any law because this is a
private area you go through the barrier
it is only hotel rules not
traffic rules smart you're smart
then when i came out they asked me
in ancient times yogis used to walk
now you drive your own car what kind of
a yogi are you then i said you idiots in
ancient times everybody was walking not
just the yogis today everybody is
driving ayogi is also driving and it
drives little better that's all the
problem is
and you drive a little better than the
average i'm guessing
i drive well enough to
though from the age of 12 i've been
riding and then driving and everything
i've driven across the world i'm still
alive so i must be driving okay
that's what i say